[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: So
welcome, everybody.
It is super exciting to
see everyone over here,
especially after nap, no
one decided to take a siesta
and join us.
So welcome, thank you very much.
Let me start by
introducing myself
and my co-presenters today.
My name is Amruta Gulanikar.
I am a Product Manager on the
Google Compute Engine team.
And I represent the team that
is responsible for making
sure Windows workloads
work great on GCE.
With me today I have
Ben and Michael.
Ben is the TL for Google's M&A
Infrastructure Service Team.
And Michael is a senior
director at Apprenda.
And he also leads the
special interest group
that is tasked with
bringing Windows
Containers to Kubernetes.
So welcome, everyone.
And let's get this show started.
So here are some cool
head shots of us,
in case our [AUDIO OUT] good.
So let's have a quick
overview of what we're going
to be talking about today.
So we're going to start with
sharing why customers want
to choose GCP for running
their Windows Workloads, what
are some of the recent
launches, and talk
a little bit about our
Windows partner program.
I'm then going to dive into some
of the key platform-specific
improvements that we have
launched, some best practices.
And then Ben is going to
come up on stage and showcase
how his team uses some of
those to manage the Windows IT
infrastructure for
alphabet companies
at acquisitions on Google Cloud.
Last but not the
least, we're going
to talk about how you can use
containers to deploy and scale
your Windows-based applications.
And Michael is going to come
and present all the great work
that the SIG has been doing to
get Windows containers support
over to Kubernetes.
Before we go into that, I really
want to iterate on our mission.
As you saw Brian Stevens,
the VP at Google Cloud,
say that Windows is
a priority for us.
And our team truly
believes that our mission
is to deliver the best
performance, security,
reliability for Windows
users on our platform.
And we've been at work
over the last year,
we have over a dozen
Windows-specific launches.
And you can see some
of them over here.
Our journey with
Windows started in 2014
when we released the first beta
for Windows Server Support.
In 2015, we GA-ed Windows
Server 2008 and 2012.
And as you can see, we've
added a ton more capabilities
in the last year--
SQL Server, VSS
integrated PD snapshots,
Cloud Tools for Visual
Studio's and PowerShell,
and SQL HA Clustering support.
So we're going to go into
a bunch of these in detail.
But along with all this
great platform support,
we are also building
an ecosystem.
We have a great set of
Windows Partners, who are not
only experts in Windows,
but also on GCP, that
can help you migrate
your Windows Workloads
from wherever they are
on-prem, colo, over to GCP.
So please, I urge you,
we announced this today.
You probably heard
Brian in his keynote.
I urge you to go
to cloud.google.com
/windows/partners and check
out our great partners.
So now let's answer
this question-- why
bring Windows Workloads to GCP?
I was talking to
a couple of folks,
and they were like,
yeah, we would
like to hear more about that.
So let's just dive in.
The first thing is
Google's infrastructure.
When you bring your
Windows Workloads to GCP,
you get all the inherent
unique capabilities
of our infrastructure.
Your traffic will never leave
Google's privately-owned fiber
network even when you
go between data centers.
What this means for you is that
you get super low latencies,
a consistent throughput,
fast VM boot up times,
and autoscaling that just works.
And this is one of
the main reasons why
we have a ton of gaming
companies and enterprise
companies who
really love running
Windows Workloads on GCP.
For folks who like
transparent maintenance,
we have live migration.
Your VMs can move
from different hosts
without any impact
to your workload.
And if you are really
interested in running SQL Server
Workloads on us,
we give 40k IOPS
on our persistent disk
storage at no extra cost.
Price-- price is
always very important.
We really strive to give a very
simple and intuitive pricing
model.
If you see our
Windows pricing, it's
$0.04 per core, per hour,
for all your VM types.
So if you want to understand
what your cost is going to be,
there's a very simple and
easy way to calculate it,
no hidden costs.
Most Windows
Workloads run 24 by 7.
And at the end of it you get
a sustained use discount,
which gives you up
to a 30% lower cost
at the end of the
month just by running
your workload steady state.
We announced the committed
use discount program today.
If you want to
look at longer term
commitments for your
steady state workloads,
we have that option too.
One of the biggest
things that customers
love when they come
to our platform
is the flexibility
of custom VMs.
Custom VMs is a great example.
You don't really need to be
locked into any predefined VM.
So think about if you're
running SQL Server.
You don't need to run
it on a 16-core VM
when you just need 10 vCPUs.
And that is really powerful,
especially for Windows,
because not only are you
getting the machine shape
that you exactly want,
but you no longer
have to pay license costs
for those extra vCPUs,
as licensing is tied to cores.
So as we make progress
in getting machines which
have higher memory
with lower CPU use,
you can take full
advantage of that.
Now, I talked about a
bunch of these which
were very across the platform.
Let's talk about
some Windows-specific
reasons to bring your
Workloads to GCP.
We support SQL Server and
Windows Server images.
You could run SQL
Server even before.
But now we have introduced
support for SQL Server AlwaysOn
Availability Groups.
So you can have the
same HA configuration
that you had on-premise
on GCE Windows VMs today.
We have things like Volume
Shadow Copy Service, which
is very critical for
enterprise workloads who
want to back up their data
disks in a reliable manner
without affecting
their workload.
We have Tools, the Interactive
Serial Port Access.
You have tools for Visual
Studio, PowerShell,
all the .net developers in the
room have ample support to run,
to write there ASP.NET or
ASP.NET Core applications
on our platform.
In the same spirit of
flexibility, customers ask me,
I have existing
license for SQL Server.
Can I bring them on?
Yes, you can bring on your
existing EEs with software
assurance over to GCP.
And all these features and wide
range of Windows and SQL Server
images that I mentioned
are available to you
in the free trials.
So if you are new
to the platform,
you want to give it a try,
register in our free trial
program.
And you can try all of these
for $300 credits, 12 months.
So hopefully these
are some good reasons.
And our customers
really value some
of these when they bring
their applications to us.
Now let's talk about
bringing your VMs to GCE.
A lot of customers have
existing VM on-premise
that they want to
bring over to GCE.
And we have a great
partnership with CloudEndure
which will migrate your Windows
VMs to GCE at no charge.
Could that be better?
We recommend that you go into
our UI on our Cloud console.
Right next to
Creating an Instance,
you'll have a nice button
there which says Import VM.
And you will be able to
follow a very simple process
to bring over your Windows VMs.
We have a full range of planning
and implementation partners.
So really I encourage you to go
check out cloud.google/migrate
for details, or come up
and ask me questions.
So let's say we don't
want to migrate a VM.
I just want to spin up a new VM.
What do we support?
We have a really long list of
Windows Server images and SQL
Server images that we support.
I'd like to point out that we
released support for Windows
Server 2016 last year.
And we did that within a week
of Microsoft GA-ing their new OS
version.
And I like to point that
out because this really
shows that we are
committed to making sure
that anything that is the
latest technology on Windows
is available on
our platform too.
And it also points to
the great relationship
that we have with Microsoft
in helping us doing
this in a really timely manner.
We have support for Core
and Nano coming soon.
And a lot of customers asked
us for SQL Server images.
So these are images with
the licensing including.
You don't need a supply.
You don't need to buy
licensing anywhere.
It is pay as you go,
per minute billing.
Now, when we talk about SQL
Server the very next question
is-- do you have HA support?
And as I mentioned,
yes, we do have
support for high availability
using AlwaysOn Availability
Groups.
Now this is very similar
to what you would probably
have on-premise.
You can deploy a
multi-node SQL cluster,
set up your availability
group listener,
join it to your AD
domain, and have
it work just like you had
it working on-premise.
Yesterday we did a great
demonstration of this
and demonstrated failover.
If you want to go
and see that talk,
please look at the recording
for running SQL Servers.
But one thing I'd
really like to point out
is we have detailed
guides and scripts.
But setting up SQL HA
is not an easy process.
Anyone who has set
up a SQL HA before?
Oh, a few of you.
So you know that this
is a multi-step process.
A lot of things can go wrong.
And just to get a proof of
concept takes a bunch of time.
So what we've done is we've
got a Cloud Launcher template.
In one click, you can set up
a multi-node cluster for you
in your project.
And this is great if you
want to do a quick BOC,
you want to test
failover, just see
how it works on the platform.
So really I encourage you
to go and try that out.
We talked about VSS.
The reason I want to
really stress on VSS
is what you get with VSS is
application consistent backups
for your data disks on
SQL Server without having
to turn out your VM.
Now, this is a service that is
supported by Windows Server.
And applications like SQL
Server have great native support
for VSS writers.
And this is really a
great, unique capability
on our platform
that will allow you
to have more reliable backup
and disaster recovery solutions.
So now we've set up all our VMs.
We've deployed a bunch
of HA configurations.
Simple question, how
do I access my VMs?
So you can access your VMs using
RTP, by default that is open.
But we've also supported WinRM
for all our Windows and SQL
Server images.
So you can really take advantage
of running HTTPS, WinRM
over HTTPS, and
accessing your VMs.
I also talked a little
bit about Tools.
Once your instance
is set up, how
do you exactly know that
it is set up correctly?
So let me show you some
of the cool things you
can do with the Interactive
Serial Port Access Control.
I'm going to call this ISPAC,
because Interactive Serial Port
Access Control is a
real tongue twister.
So you'll see me
saying ISPAC a bunch.
So that's what it is.
OK.
So switching over
to my demo machine.
As you can see, I've just spun
up a simple Windows Instance.
This is based on the
Windows Server 2016 image.
And I'm going to try to see
if this instance was set up
correctly.
So I'm going to click on in.
And I'm going to scroll down.
I see this View Serial Port
And I'm going to click on it.
And it will show me that the
instance was set up correctly.
I have RTP set up correctly.
I have WinRM configured.
I'm good to go.
Now, let's see if I can
really RTP into this machine.
It's taking some time,
longer than expected.
Oh, there seems to be an error.
So it says that the remote
access server is not enabled,
or the machine's not running.
So I can definitely see
that the machine's running.
I saw that RTP was
configured on my instance.
So what do I do now?
So we have interactive--
we have ISPAC.
So I'm going to connect to the
serial port really quickly.
And just to save some time
while this [INAUDIBLE],
then I'll switch back, I
actually already logged in.
So let's see if it reconnects.
All right, I'm going to
punch in my password.
And there you go.
If you are a Windows
SS admin, you
will recognize this console.
You didn't have to
leave the web browser.
And you have access to this.
Now, I can run
things, like, hey,
did it also lose
internet connectivity?
Is this actually connected?
So I'm going to see--
yeah, it seems to be connected
to the internet fine.
Most of the problems that
we see with RTP not working
is the Windows Firewall.
The rules are not enabled
or it's just not on.
So let's just do a quick check
on what the Windows Firewall
status is.
Oh, the Windows Firewall is off.
No wonder RTP is not working.
So let's go and restart that.
I think I made a--
let's type that again.
Apparently I can't type today.
There you go.
So the Windows
Firewall has started.
Now, let me see if that
really fixed that issue.
So let me go up.
And really from the
browser, try to RTP in--
super convenient.
There you go.
Someone messed up
the Windows Firewall.
That was me.
But this was just
for demo purposes.
So switching back to slides.
So you can see that
we really worked hard
on making sure that sudden
difficult problems are
made really super easy for you.
And that's the
advantage of running
Windows Workloads on us.
So we had that quick demo.
So now you've deployed
these machines,
but you're not going to do
this one machine at a time.
You want to deploy this
in a scalable fashion.
And we have some great tools
with startup and shutdown
scripts that allow
you to do this.
So I'm going to have Ben
up on stage to demonstrate
how their team takes
a code-driven approach
to manage ID infrastructure
for alphabet companies who
are running Windows
on Google Cloud.
Ben?
BEN MILLER: Thanks, Amruta.
Hi, my name is Ben Miller.
I work for Google's Mergers
and Acquisitions Infrastructure
Services Team.
And I'm here to talk to you
about our project GECCO, which
is currently managing Windows
instances in Google Cloud.
So what is GECCO?
GECCO is code-driven, managed
IT infrastructure for alphabet
entities and acquisitions.
Alphabet entities are
separate companies.
And so they often don't have
access to Google corporate IT
infrastructure.
Although GECCO needs customer
environments, excuse me,
although each GECCO customer
needs an independent IT
infrastructure for a
variety of reasons,
we need a scalable
solution for management
of those environments.
We strive to achieve this
through services, policies,
and standards that we can
define in code and deploy
through automation.
Our customers don't want
to spend time and energy
reinventing the
wheels themselves,
so they order their
wheels from us.
GECCO environments contain
Linux and Windows workstations,
excuse me, instances,
and use Active Directory
for directory services.
We provide Cloud-hosted
infrastructure services
to GECCO customers, services
like Active Directory, Network
Infrastructure and
Security Services,
Central File Sharing,
Disaster Recovery.
Our goal is to scalably
manage infrastructure services
in per customer
deployments, following
shared best practices, and using
a shared management framework.
GECCO achieves this
in part by automating
the deployment and configuration
of per customer GCE
environments.
Here's a very high level example
of what one might look like.
A typical GECCO
environment is comprised
of a customer-specific
GCE project connected
to the customer's on-site
network via Cloud VPN.
Typically, the project will
span multiple geographic regions
for fault tolerance.
Each GECCO service
is expressed in code
that defines well-understood
and well-tested behaviors.
This functional code does
not change from one customer
to the next.
Each GECCO customer
environment is
defined in a customer-specific
repository, which
contains structured
configuration
files, certificates,
and other things that
are specific to that customer.
This repository
defines all aspects
of the customer environment--
from host level configuration,
to configuration parameters
that specialize the behavior
of each GECCO service.
This repository links
back to the main GECCO
source, where all of the
functional code is maintained.
Now, this link can point
to the most recent version
of the GECCO code
where it can be
pinned to a specific version.
This simplifies
maintenance and upgrades
as new versions of
GECCO and GECCO services
can be rolled out over time.
The separation between
functional code
in GECCO and customer
configuration
can be seen from the
beginning during the instance
build process.
GECCO instances are built
using a function that we define
in our GECCO PowerShell module.
The instance can be built
simply by referring to its name,
and all of the necessary
details to build
that instance will be
extracted from the customer's
configuration.
Now let me focus for a moment
on how Google Compute Engine has
simplified Windows instance
building and configuration.
First, let me call out the
Google Cloud PowerShell module.
The folks in Google
Cloud have provided us
with some fantastic
tools to manage
GCE resources using PowerShell.
I'll be using commandlets from
this module to demonstrate
how we build Windows
infrastructure.
Now let's talk about
the build image.
The Windows Server
image provided by GCE
is kept up-to-date for you
with the latest hot fixes,
so you don't have to
maintain that yourself.
When you boot a Windows
image for the first time
in Google Cloud, it boots
into the sysprep-specialize
configuration pass.
And for those of you who are
less familiar with sysprep,
what this means is that the
first time a Windows instance
is spun up in your
project, it runs
a series of
specialization tasks that
finalize the Windows install.
GCE gives you several options
to inject custom scripts
into this process without
rebuilding the image.
And one of these options is
to leverage the GCE metadata
service to store an
instance-specific script that
will be executed during
the specialized pass.
And that's what we do.
Note that this is in addition
to the startup and shutdown
scripts you can also
define in metadata
that will run at each startup
and shutdown of the instance.
GECCO uses sysprep-specialize
as an opportunity
to inject a very simple script
to bootstrap the GECCO build
and configuration process.
OK.
Can we switch to the
demo computer, please?
OK.
The code that you will
see here is representative
of the process of the
GECCO Project employees,
but it is, of course,
not exactly the same code
that we use in production.
Here we have a short
script that will be used
to build a Windows instance.
What we've done here is
reference the current GCE
Windows Server 2016
Core image, populate
the appropriate metadata
with our bootstrap script,
and call Add GCE instance
to create the new machine.
This commandlet is part of the
Google Cloud PowerShell module.
As you can see, you
can also add a startup
and/or shut down
script at the same time
when you are creating
the instance.
So while this runs,
let me show you
how instance metadata becomes
a sysprep-specialize script.
Using the get GCE
instance commandlet
you can retrieve an
object that describes
all of the attributes
of your GCE instances.
Now, here I've drilled
down specifically just
to list the instance metadata.
You can see that the
startup, shutdown,
and sysprep-specialize
keys have been populated
with the values we provided when
the instance was first created.
And when a Windows
instance is first created,
the GCE agent on
that machine looks
for the sysprep-specialize key
in the GCP metadata service.
And if it exists,
it executes it.
This is a really
low-friction way
of customizing your
Windows instance builds.
As the script
executes, its output
is mirrored to the
instances serial port.
You already saw some of that
in Amruta's demonstration,
but I want to show you how
this works in PowerShell.
You can observe the serial
output of your GCP instances
by using the Cloud console or
by using the get GCE instance
commandlet.
You can see low-level output
of the instance boot process,
as well as other messages that
are logged by the GCE agent.
And if I do a little
bit of quick filtering,
we should see just the
output of the scripts
that we defined in metadata.
The output is
truncated somewhat,
but you can see what
I've done there.
As the script executes-- oh,
excuse me, one more slide.
There we go.
OK.
Let's go back to
the slides, please.
So to recap, using
Google Cloud PowerShell
we were able to reference a
pre-built Windows Server Core
image, defined
startup, shutdown,
and sysprep-specialize scripts,
and create a GCE instance.
We were also able to monitor
the progress of the instances
build using serial output.
And we did all of this
from within PowerShell.
Now, for GECCO, now that
we have built an instance,
how will it be
configured and managed?
In a nutshell, GECCO uses
customer configuration files
to drive PowerShell Desired
State Configuration.
How does this work?
Well, each GECCO environment
has a configuration master.
In DSC terms, this is
called a pull server.
The config master iterates over
the list of all GECCO instances
defined in the customer config.
Based on the roles and services
associated with each instance,
templates are merged
together to construct
the full configuration
for the instance.
Within each
configuration template
are DSC resources,
whose attributes
are populated using
properties that
are stored also in the
customer configuration file.
The output of this process is
a compiled DSC configuration
for each instance which
the pull server will host.
And on a schedule,
managed instances
will pull their new
configuration and apply them.
They will report back to
the config master with data
on what changes were
made and whether or not
the configuration was
applied successfully.
Now, this is not a
one-time operation.
Managed instances
will continually
re-evaluate their configuration
and ensure that the desired
configuration is applied.
So our instances have
been built and configured.
How do we make changes to
a customer environment?
Our management pipeline is
driven by open source projects.
We use Gerrit for
Git-based code review
and Jenkins for
continuous integration.
GECCO strives to be a
management framework
with strong accountability
for changes.
So how do we achieve this?
First, a GECCO admin
submits a change for review.
Now, this does not alter
the customer environment,
but it's a proposed change.
This change can be anything
from a new DNS record,
to a change to Group
Policy, to firewall rules,
just to name a few examples.
Now, this proposed change needs
approval from two sources.
First, our Jenkins
instance will automatically
run unit and integration tests.
And second, another member
of the GECCO admin team
has to review the commit
and provide final approval.
Now, finally, once
all this is done,
the configuration master
will recompile instance
configurations
based on the change,
and the GECCO instances
will pick up those changes.
Now, this management pipeline
is the core of GECCO.
But why?
Why did we take this approach to
systems administration instead
of managing things in a
more traditional fashion?
By defining our architecture
in code and config,
we can have strong assurance
that the infrastructure is
built and operates as designed.
When we implement
best practices,
we are able to implement
across all of our customers.
And by standardizing the
services that we deploy,
and the way in which
we deploy them,
we are able to manage
many customer environments
using the same set of
management tools and procedures.
All of this allows
us to scale support
for additional customers without
having to also linearly scale
the size of our team.
But why do we choose
to build GECCO on GCE?
Well, first of all,
we take a lot of value
from GCE's specific support
for Windows as a platform.
Custom instance
sizing and simple
hosted Windows
licensing makes it easy
for us to predict invoice
costs per customer.
Building Windows VMs on GCE
is really fast and simple
to automate.
And Google Cloud PowerShell
is a huge win for us,
allowing us to automate GCE
using the same management
framework that we use to manage
our Windows infrastructure.
Now, finally, as a
customer of Google Cloud,
the single biggest win is
the performance, stability,
and security of GCP.
It allows our team to focus
on just those challenges that
are ours to solve.
Now, let me hand the
time back to Amruta,
who's going to talk about
container support for Windows
Workloads.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
Thank you, Ben.
So you saw a great demonstration
of how you can configure
Windows infrastructure on GCE.
A question I often get from
customers more recently
is, how do you deploy your
Windows-based applications
using containers?
And the answer is there
are many different paths
that you can take on GCP.
You can stand up a Windows
server VM, Windows Server
2016, which is the first version
to support Docker and Windows
Server containers, and run your
Windows containers on that.
We also have support for Nano
Silver, which is coming soon,
which will have a much
smaller footprint.
You can choose to
have ASP.NET Core apps
and run them in either Windows
Silver containers or Linux
containers.
You have options when you
want to manage orchestration
of your containers.
And you can either choose
Kubernetes or Google Compute
Engine.
So today, if you have
an ASP.NET Core app,
you can run it on
a Linux container
on Google Container Engine.
We are also contributing to the
open source special interest
group that I mentioned,
which is tasked
with bringing Windows containers
support to Kubernetes.
And if you want an even
more managed solution,
then you can--
we just launched
support for ASP.NET Core
on App Engine Flex, or App
Engine Flexible Environments.
So you can have multiple
different options.
Now, in order to demonstrate the
great work that the open source
community has been doing
for Windows containers
and Kubernetes, I'd like
to call up Michael on stage
to talk more about that.
MICHAEL MICHAEL:
Thank you, Amruta.
Hi, everybody.
So I'm here representing
the Special Interest
Group for Windows
Server containers
from the Kubernetes community.
So a quick show of hands, how
many of you guys have used
Kubernetes so far, whether
on-premise or in a Cloud
provider, like Google Cloud?
All right, a few of you guys.
So one of the most
important things
is if you are using
Kubernetes, it
is one of the best
tools out there
to be able to
[AUDIO OUT], manage,
deploy containers at scale.
It really makes life simple.
So if you are deploying
containers today
in traditional virtual machines,
or whether that's on-premise,
or in a Cloud provider, it's
hard to actually make sure
what image are you using,
control the workflow,
whether that's a
continuous integration
or a continuous
deployment system,
and being able to scale those.
With Kubernetes, you
have a complete platform
that manages the end-to-end
lifecycle of your containers.
From the point where you
define where the application
you want to run
into the container,
to defining the
networking for it,
being able to scale it to the
hundreds or thousands of nodes,
and then being able
to version that and go
from version 1 to version
2, and so on and so forth.
So within the community, which
has been running for a while
now, one thing was lacking.
And that was Windows
Server support.
So the SIG Windows
team was tasked
to go and bring Windows
Server support to Kubernetes,
and more importantly, to be
able to run Windows Server
containers.
What that will give us is one
of the best cross-platform,
heterogeneous cluster monitors.
And it would allow us to expand
the types of applications
that can run on Kubernetes.
So before, you used to have
applications that will run
on the Linux operating system.
By introducing Windows
Server containers,
now you can run
IIS-based applications.
You can run .net
Core applications.
You can run Windows services
and any other application
that can on the Windows OS.
So that's a tremendous
amount of change introduced
to Kubernetes now
with the ability
to run all these
extra workloads.
And all of our work here in
the Special Interest Group
is really based
on top of the work
that Microsoft has done to
both introduce Windows Server
containers to their
operating system
as well as a lot of the
networking enhancements
that have been made.
There's a few companies
that I want to call out here
that have been doing a
lot of work in the group,
and that's Apprenda,
where I'm coming from.
There's CloudBase, Google,
Microsoft, and Red Hat as well.
All these guys are contributing
to make this a reality.
From a status
perspective, we have Alpha
support in Kubernetes today.
So you can go and download
our binaries and try this out.
And with the release
of Kubernetes
that will come towards the
end of Q2 of this year,
we'll go in beta.
So let's take a look at the
architecture really quickly.
One of the things that
we wanted to make sure
is that we kept the simplicity
of Kubernetes and Docker
as it exists today.
So on the left-hand side,
you have the existing Docker
architecture for
Linux on Kubernetes.
And you'll see that you have
the Docker images, the engine,
and then you have a shared
Kernel down at the bottom,
where you can have one or
more containers running on top
of the same container host.
That's the compute unit
that's running your ecosystem.
And on the right side, when
we started architecting things
for the Windows side,
it was very advantageous
that Docker now runs
on Windows Server.
And it has a very similar model
to what they are in Linux,
so we maintain the parity
of having the Docker
images on the node.
You have your Docker
engine daemon,
which is what we are
talking to as Kubernetes,
and then having one or
more containers running
on top of a shared Kernel.
I would like to point out
that Windows Server supports
two types of containers today.
One of it is Windows
Server containers,
where you have a shared Kernel.
And it also supports
Hyper-V containers,
where you have kernel
mode isolation as well.
Right now we have been
predominantly working
on Windows Server
containers, but there's
nothing that prevents us from
supporting Hyper-V containers
as well as we go towards beta.
With the alpha
support that we had,
this is what our
architecture looked like.
So you have the
Physical Internet
coming up from the top.
And then you have the
kubelet and the kube-proxy,
which are the two components of
Kubernetes that kind of drive
the core functionality.
And then you have an
abstraction called
a pod, which is the lowest unit
of deployment in Kubernetes
that can contain one
or more containers.
Think of a pod as
a microservice,
for example, that
can be implemented
inside one or more containers.
So with the alpha support, this
is what it would look like.
And we went ahead and completely
rewrote the networking stack
of Kubernetes for
Windows Server containers
as we march towards beta
to eliminate completely
the kube-proxy and use OVN
and OVS as the networking
backbone for the containers.
This provided us a tremendous
amount of advantages.
And it allows us as we
move towards the future
to support things
like network overlays
and be able to do
a network namespace
isolation for containers that
spans both Windows and Linux.
So imagine this, you'll be able
to have a single application
that has containers running
on Linux and on Windows, both
of them in a single
network namespace,
communicating with each other
in a secure and scalable manner.
So let's switch here
to a demo and show you
some of this work in real time.
And what you're looking at
here is the Google Cloud
as the k-shell.
So all of our components here
are running in Google Cloud.
So I'm going to go
ahead and create an SSH
session to my Kubernetes
master component.
So I will go ahead and
change the resolution here
so you guys can see
that fairly well.
All right, so the first
thing I'm going to do
is we're going to go ahead
and run as administrator here.
And I'm going to run kubectl.
This is the command line
interface with Kubernetes.
And I'm going to go ahead
and get all the nodes that we
have in the system here.
And notice that
I have two nodes.
I have a master component
that's running on Linux.
And it contains all of the
core pieces to run Kubernetes.
And then the second
thing I have is
I have a worker node that's
running Windows Server that is
able to host pods on Windows.
So if I check if I
have any pods here,
you'll notice that I don't have
any pods deployed right now.
So there's no resources
deployed in the system.
To demonstrate here some of
the capabilities of our node,
let's go ahead and
describe the Windows node.
And notice that its
architecture is AMD64.
It's running the same kubelet
and kube-proxy version
that the rest of my Kubernetes
environment is running.
And it has the same
type of details
in terms of the CPU
performance metrics,
the memory metrics, and all
the other details, like labels,
that Kubernetes has.
So if I run this
command here now,
I'll be able to show you the
labels that are identifying
each node in my system.
So notice that my master
component is running
Linux with AMD64 architecture.
And now I have my
worker in Windows node
that's running the
Windows operating system.
And it's labeled accordingly.
And now this label is
important, because that's
how we're going to select pods
to be attached to that node.
So when you're deploying
containers in Kubernetes,
you get to tell
Kubernetes where would you
like those to be deployed.
Think of this as a
simple deployment policy.
And we'll use the labels
that are identifying
each one of our nodes.
So let's get started here.
Let's go ahead and
deploy some containers.
So the first containers
I'm going to go ahead
and deploy is the first
tier of my application.
And this is a Redis cache
that will form the data
part of my application.
So my application is going
to be a microservice that
has three components-- a
redis-slave, a redis-master,
as well as a guestbook
Go application-- running
all of these components
running on Windows.
But there's nothing preventing
me from running one of them
on Linux if I so choose.
So we want to have them
deploy the redis-master.
So I can go ahead and run
my pods command again.
And now notice that I
have a single instance
of my redis-master running here.
So if I run my command
kubectl logs and point it
to the redis-master, notice
does that we have redis-3.0.504
running inside Windows.
So let's go ahead and
create the slave now
that will communicate
with the master pod
to complete the second
tier of our application.
And one of the things
I want to show you
is what does that look like.
So let's go ahead and
do that and look at one
of the Redis components here.
So this is a deployment
specification on Kubernetes.
So the pod, that abstraction
I mentioned earlier,
is defined using a
specification like this.
So in this deployment
specification
I'm indicating that my
name is redis-slave.
And I want to use this specific
image from the Docker hub.
It's called
redis-slave:3.0-nanoserver.
So it's using the nanoserver OS.
And it's basically exposing
port 6379 over TCP.
And the last
important thing here
is the fact that
the node selector
is targeting Windows Server.
So now that we did this, if we
exit out of the component here
and we run our
get-pods command again,
notice now that I have two
slave redis-slave pods up
and running.
And they have a very distinct
IP address for each one of them.
And that's basically--
and they're all
running on Windows Server now.
So if I go back and check
the logs for my master,
notice now that the master
was able to communicate
with the slave at port 6379.
And that's the same port that
I identified in my description
telling it, go ahead and find
each other using that port.
So now we have two tiers of
our application up and running.
We have a redis-slave.
We have a redis-master.
They are all able to find
each other and communicate.
And they're all
running in Windows.
So let's go ahead now
and deploy the last piece
of our application, which is a
guestbook application written
in Go.
Notice now that we
created a single instance
of our guestbook application.
And I can actually go
ahead and connect to it.
So I can run kubectlexec-it
and provide the guestbook node
here.
And I'm gonna run PowerShell.
So now we have a
partial execution
inside the container that's
running our guestbook
application.
So I can run IP config here.
And I get an IP address.
And that's the IP
address on my container.
And I can even actually
ping the outside world.
You might not
think this is much,
but it took us a long
time to be able to enable
internet access inside a
container using the OVN overlay
network.
So we had to introduce
things like a gateway node,
and be able to
route the traffic,
create the correct inter-pod and
inter-container connectivity.
So even though this is simple,
and we all take internet access
for granted, this was a lot
of work to make that happen.
So now we actually
have our pods.
We have the service as well
and three different sets
of pods that comprise
this specific service.
So let's go ahead and describe
our service in Kubernetes.
And just a few details
here about our service
that were taken out
of the specification.
You have a guestbook
application.
It has an IP address.
It has a couple
of different ports
that you can use to access it.
And I can actually go ahead
and run a call command here
against that application.
And we'll go ahead and
change the IP address here.
And notice that it returned
back some data telling me,
hey, you're on
container 10 24 9.4.
More importantly, I can switch
over here to my Windows node.
That is the Windows node.
That's the worker node
that's part of my cluster.
And notice everything
is running on GCP here.
I can switch on this node.
And I can open up a web
browser and hit my guestbook
application.
And I can enter some data here.
And I'm going to call
it audience1, 2, and 3.
So if I go back
to my script here
and I run the call
command again,
I'm getting back the
data because I was
able to query that application.
So let's go ahead
and scale it and see
some of the advantages
of Kubernetes.
So I'm going to
run a command here
that essentially is
instructing Kubernetes
to increase the
deployment of guestbook
to a three replica count.
So if I run my
getpods command again,
I get to see that guestbook now
has three instances running.
Now, all three
instances are going
to be load balanced
by Kubernetes.
So as a developer, I don't
have to do anything extra.
I can take advantage of the
complete backbone of Kubernetes
that will handle routing, load
balancing, full tolerance,
high availability.
And all I had to do was
deploy my application.
And all of those things
are taken for granted.
And they're available
to me to use.
So now I can go back to
my web browser again.
And as I refresh, I can see the
endpoints changing sometimes.
Now, there are sticky sessions
happening in the web browser,
so you might not be able
to see this clearly.
So I went ahead and
wrote the script here
that will invoke the URI
for my application 20 times
and print the contents.
And notice here that
every time we invoke it,
the IP address sometimes changes
because Kubernetes is basically
load balancing the requests to
my application based on number
of requests per second.
So some of them are hitting
the container at p.4, 192,
and I actually should have
a third one here as well.
So if we go up, we should
be able to see the 187 IP
address as well here.
So those other three IP
addresses are part of my pod
that are available for load
balancing for my application.
And if we go back
to guestbook here,
if I click the
environment variables,
it is clearly evident here
that I'm running on Windows.
This is Windows
Server containers.
I'm able to see
all the information
about the Redis cache that
is part of my application.
And I can come
back into the node,
and I can run Docker
commands, like Docker images,
and see the images
that I was able to use
for the deployment
of my application.
Or run docker ps and look
at all the containers
that were deployed by
Kubernetes as part of my app.
So Kubernetes
handled everything,
from the deployment
of containers,
the setting up of the networking
backbone, the load balancing,
as well as making sure that my
containers are up and running
and highly available.
Let's go ahead and
switch to the slides.
So we showed you how
Kubernetes and the community
is bringing Windows
Server support
into the entire ecosystem.
We're encouraging
everybody, if you
want to get involved
or even try this work,
go ahead and find us on Slack.
You can also visit
our GitHub page.
And we encourage
everybody that's
passionate about Windows,
passionate about orchestrators
and cluster managers, to
come along, go ahead and get
involved.
Try out our capabilities
or create a PR
and introduce some of your
own code into the mix.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
Wasn't that awesome?
So we've taken you
through this journey
and kind of told you
some of the capabilities
of the platform, some
reasons that will give you
some really great
advantages by bringing
Windows workloads to us.
We have tools to bring your
traditional Windows workloads.
And we have some
great set of tools
if you want to
modernize your Windows
workloads with Kubernetes
support, with App Engine Flex,
and so on and so forth.
So we have a ton of resources
at cloud.google.com/windows/,
/sql-server, /dotnet.
So we really encourage
you to kind of go and do
a deeper dive.
And now we can open
up for some questions.
So I have up here, before
we go into questions,
some of the talks.
Now, we were the last talk.
So there were some 200
and 300 level deep dives.
And our session sort of
brought it all together
to give you a quick summary.
But please look
at the recordings
if you've missed any.
And there's a Meet our Experts
session going on right now.
I think you'll probably
have an hour for that, too.
So please attend that, too.
So with that,
hopefully we answered
some of your questions.
And if not, we're here.
I'd like to call Michael,
Ben, up on stage, and also
[? Phong, ?] who was the
TL for Windows, up on stage
to take any of your questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]